I know everyone and thank you all for
joining me for this rather
unconventional talk for PI data
conference quanta mental investing my
name is Fabian Claus and I run the Kwan
technology team at man gog and the
purpose of this team is essentially to
bring quanta mental approaches to life
build systems around quanta mental and
help all portfolio managers make better
decisions who of you knows the term
quantum mental who is heard of it and
who of those actually know what it means
cool so most most of you will learn
something something very new today
spoiler alert
there will be no Python code in this
presentation I'm sorry about that but
I'll share what kind of systems we're
building around the the idea of quantum
mental investing what kind of lessons
lessons we've learned in the last couple
of years and also how Python helps us to
bring these to life so man GOG is part
of man group and we are operating
worldwide we have large and Sinti
institutional client base mainly
sovereign wealth funds endowments
pension funds we manage around one
hundred twelve billion dollars and we
are split roughly and in five business
units we've got a gel a numeric on the
quantitative side we've got Man GOG the
part of the business that I now work in
as our discretionary manager we also
have a private markets business and in
GPM and the multi manager and frm the
the main takeaway here is that we're
doing quite a lot of things at quite a
large scale we have 25 to 30 years
experience in both be systematic and the
discretionary space in mang group is a
very tech driven tech driven company
we've basically consolidated all our
front office technology under the newer
Brella of man AlphaTech all based on
Python so we're we're essentially in the
perfect place to bring these quanta
mental approaches to life to get this
fusion going between discretionary and
systemic trading and don't worry I've
already used quite a lot of Finance
terms I'll make sure that we speak the
same language and just just a bit so my
rough goal for today is to give you an
idea of what quanta mental investing is
why do we actually need it we
already have big businesses around
systemic trading about discretionary
trading what does it actually give us
what kind of problems does it solve then
I will give you an overview of what kind
of systems we've actually built to help
output for your managers make better
decisions and also share share the
lessons learned in the last couple of
years but let's make sure that we all
speak the same language quant or
systematic trading is essentially a
computer driven trading algorithms make
the decisions we have one researchers
who come up with a model as to how to
use market data transferred in different
ways you stats use machine learning to
come up with a signal as to whether to
buy or to sell certain instruments build
a portfolio around it and then execute
that in the market the characteristic of
such portfolios is generally that you
have a large number of instruments or
stocks when you when you trade cash
equities you almost have like an
unlimited ability to process data
depending on what what your clusters
what the cluster is capable of depending
on what kind of machines you have you
have in your new company so the main
selling point around systematic trading
is you're following a model you take the
emotions out of the game and you make
let the computers just do do its thing
on it on a daily basis however you can
also only use quantifiable information
anything that is not specified upfront
in your model you can't really
incorporate into your trading process so
you limit it to that regard
on the other hand discretionary trading
and that's also where the space that man
GOG operates and is driven by humans
humans analyze companies they meet with
the company boards they look at broker
reports they look at news events they
incorporate all kinds of information
about a certain company in the trading
process and make up their mind as to
whether to sell or to buy certain
certain companies these portfolio is
obviously quite concentrated because our
we humans were quite limited in our
ability to process data so we can only
look at so many companies or so many
instruments but we are also able or
discretionary portfolio managers are
able to use non quantifiable information
anything that that comes comes up about
around the company about Iran an
instrument anything that is not even
related to these companies but might
have some macro effects
be incorporated in your trading process
and quanta mental is really the blend of
these two approaches you take
quantitative techniques you take
fundamental investing you mix in some
data if you're really fancy nowadays you
call it alternative data so credit card
data or satellite images to track the
number of cars in front of shops to come
up with an idea of whether they're doing
well or not and eval are you get your
new password of the discretionary
community quanta mental but to make all
this a little bit more tangible for you
let's look at the trading process and
the way I see the trading process I
roughly divided in five stages obviously
they're different ways and how how you
can do it but in my mind you start with
the universe screening stage you need to
narrow down the amount of instruments
that you could trade to the amount that
you actually want to do research on I
wanna run your models on in a
discretionary environment obviously a
portfolio manager I can't meet with all
companies a world why they need to
narrow that down systematic signals or
systematic strategies want to usually
look at the most liquid names so they
throw out less liquid instruments so
that it can quickly trade in and out of
positions and then once you have your
universe you start doing fundamental
research on that universe you meet with
the company boards you read broker
research and you make up your mind as to
whether you like certain instrument or
you don't like it in a systemic
environment that might just be number
crunching exercise you take market data
and run your model and come up with the
signal as to whether to buy or to sell
certain instruments once you have these
instruments and you have your indication
as to whether you would like them or not
you build a portfolio around them you
run a portfolio optimizer and you
execute that in the market in the last
step you you look at how we put four
years doing what you want to monitor
whether you you're actually making money
whether you're losing money whether your
original ideas pan out in a systemic
world you also want to see whether the
simulation that you came up with all
that you put your research I came up
with a new partner environment actually
reflects your live trading P&L and the
way we seek wonda mental is essentially
enrichment of the traditional
discretionary manager's trading process
by a technology each of these five
stages will be enriched by technology
will be enriched by kuan techniques
and we'll try to make them better at
what they do so we see the Conda mental
as an enrichment of a fundamental
research process use new datasets
combine them in different ways use
quanta now these to answer very complex
questions that you can't do just with
Excel spreadsheets and I'll give you a
couple of examples of what we've done in
the past later on also you can use Kwan
signals in your universe screening stage
we've built sentiment indicators using
NLP on earnings called transcripts to
give all portfolio managers and I an
idea of whether it was a good positive
or a negative earnings call also you can
use breakout signals we also think about
quantum ental in terms of all the tools
that deal with behavioral biases and go
into behavioral biases and and in a few
moments lastly even though that's not
it's not quite quanta mental but we also
use it under the same umbrella as
essentially generating efficiencies for
portfolio managers we want to make sure
that in the trading process that you
just saw you the the portfolio managers
or we automate the stages that can
easily be automated by computers where
they're basically wasting their time for
example copying data from one
spreadsheet to another writer you don't
need a human to do that there are lots
of lots of systems that can do that so
that they can really focus on their
value add focus on their fundamental
research process look at more company do
more in-depth analyses and become better
investors as a as a whole but I've
already told you that we have large
businesses around the systemic side
discretionary aside they're huge
industries build around both approaches
why do we actually need anything
fundamental what does it give us on top
and as Python enthusiasts and computer
scientists you probably think well I can
just build a computer model that does
everything for me right well the problem
is you know when you work in complex
domains you can't really come up with a
proper mathematical model to model
reality perfectly yeah they're always
changing underlying assumptions your
market conditions might change how do
you put a brexit into your model yeah
and for fans of Nassim collapse work on
the Black Swan a lot of the kuan
techniques are also based around the
idea of normality of your data and that
might not be
really the case in real life a couple of
examples where were these where we can't
really build systematic strategies
around around certain store certain
ideas or investment ideas are for
example merger arbitrage therefore for
making money out of different mergers
companies you really need to understand
the legal the legal groundwork yeah we
weren't able to come up with computers
they can actually do that job for us so
we have humans looking at that and
another really good examples index
events for those of you who don't know
index providers MSCI or footsie they
basically define their base universes so
for example the MSCI world contains the
biggest companies in the world then you
have ETFs who map these indices we
actually make them accessible for you as
an individual to trade in them to get
exposure to them to get the same returns
that your index would what would get
these ETFs essentially need to rebalance
every time the index comes up with a new
list of stocks which should be in and
out of the index
so on a quarterly basis they'd have
these big rebalance events and you would
think that
MSCI and footsie they provide me with a
detail rulebook I think the MSC is is
around 800 pages long so you can you can
basically code that up step by step and
come up with your prediction that on
each day you know what should be in the
index and what shouldn't the problem is
that these index providers also apply
quite a lot of this question in the in
their process so for example in May 2019
Argentina was moved from being a
frontier market to becoming an emerging
market and that essentially I mean
doesn't really sound like a big deal of
emerging market frontier what does that
even mean but it essentially means that
you're your base universe of companies
who should be in each of these buckets
changes completely and you will get all
your predictions wrong because if you
and these index advanced traders if you
get one prediction wrong you basically
get them all wrong yeah and so you if
you're trading index events you really
need a human analyst who keeps in touch
with the index providers who keeps in
touch with the broadcast force the news
to anticipate these these changes and
make sure that your model is not not
completely going look so should we just
let humans make all of the decisions
then you'll go back to traditional
trading well you all know that we're
quite
ability to process data we are very bad
at statistical reasoning and in order to
become really good at something we
require a frequent feedback loop that is
not really given in financial markets
because you will never encounter the
same situation twice right market
conditions will always change even just
like a small variable might might be
different next time you encounter
similar conditions and we underlie
behavioural Bay biases I just want to
spend a few minutes looking at
behavioral biases and how they affect
our decision-making most of you will be
familiar with Daniel Kahneman his work
on cognitive limitations behavioral
biases he published his popular book
Thinking Fast and Slow around how our
decision-making is impaired by these
biases he essentially thinks of our
human mind and in terms of two systems
system one being the system that is
responsible for for fast decision-making
our intuitive intuitive part of the
brain and then you got the system tool
which is the lazy the reasoning parts
every time your system one can't handle
can't handle a question a new task and
it will defer back to system two and
system two becomes active and thinks
more deeply about around it and I won't
go into all these biases but I just want
to give you an overview of how some of
them might affect decision-making in
financial markets so I'll give you an
idea of what the anchoring effect is an
example of the framing and then we go
into overconfidence as well so the
anchoring bias essentially means that an
initial piece of information that you
see disproportionately affects you how
you see the world even though you see
lots of other even-even encounter
encounter arguments for it afterwards so
for example your your favorite broker
gives you a buy recommendation for
Vodafone yeah
if you then see lots of other brokers
saying no Vodafone is not really a good
stock you might still be biased toward
this this initial piece of information
and the way the way countermand his
colleagues test that and did their
studies on that was essentially to give
participants in two groups the same task
essentially create the product of the
first eight integers both of these
groups didn't have enough time to come
up with the correct answer they didn't
have enough time to do the mental
automatic and so they had to come up
with an educated guess the first group
was tasked to multiply numbers in an
ascending all us 1 times 2 times 3 etc
the second group in descending order 8
times 7 times 6 and what they found was
that group 1 significantly
underestimated the the true result so so
when you start with a 1 multiplying 1 by
2 by 3 you significantly Adam estimated
the true result similarly on the group
that overestimated the true result they
they also did the group multiplying
numbers in a descending order they they
overestimated the results significantly
so you can see how that affects our
decision making when we actually have to
look at financial information at
different different pieces of
information from our brokers etc an
example of the how the framing effect
might a framing effect might affect our
decision making would be to look at what
what a drug can do for you all right you
you can either frame it as this drug
this drug cures the disease in 90
percent of the cases or you could say
that even though taking this drug 10
percent of the of the trials or trial
list died using this drug and obviously
you've heard a lot about overconfidence
already over confidence in financial
markets is also a problem if you if you
think you're better than you actually
are
and the traditional research on
overconfidence was done by Rousseau on
his work on decision traps and what he's
doing is essentially he gives
participants a list of 10 questions and
for each of these 10 questions
participants are tasked to come up with
confidence intervals 90 percent
confidence interval give a lower bound
given upper bound so that you're 90
percent confidence that the true result
will lie within those and if you're well
calibrated human being you will get nine
out of these ten questions right if
you're overconfident in your ability to
answer these questions you'll get get
much fewer right so in his original work
he found that most participants only
gets four or fewer few of these answers
or these confidence intervals right
showing that there's great
overconfidence in answering these these
questions and we've replicated
actually at Man GOG last year because we
thought well maybe if you're an educated
human being you know a lot of stuff you
can actually calibrate your your your
confidence bounds a lot a lot better and
this is essentially the list of
questions that we use so we added some
listed equity market cap of the world
today a number of employees at man group
so things that you you either know and
because you've read read them or you
need to make make an estimate and we
found the same same results essentially
80% of our 46 respondents only get five
or fewer of these these right so even
even in our case there's a lot of
overconfidence at play and that is also
very in line with the academic
literature on that there Baba and odine
made did a study in 2013 investigating
the behavior of individual investors and
what they found was clear sign of
overconfidence and also clear signs of a
disposition effect so the tendency to
sell winners and as hold on to losers
and that's for individual investors
that's not only a bad investment
strategy in terms of your returns but
it's also really bad in terms of text
reasons but you might not think well
individual investors we all have
behavioral biases obviously individual
investors are not quite as experienced
as professional investors so do experts
actually do better honest well there's a
study that recently came out and I won't
even try to pronounce the name because
I'll just make a fool out of myself but
the researchers essentially investigated
783 long-only portfolio managers
long-only meaning that you can't short
sell any stocks you basically always
have to take a positive position in
something and what long-only portfolio
managers generally do is they try to
replicate a benchmark and then overall
underway it starts according to what
kind of conviction they have around them
and these portfolio managers manage
portfolios that were quite large so an
average the portfolio size was 573
million dollars so you would think that
if if you're an expert you you don't run
into these behavioral biases and you you
actually ya find find reasonable and
make reasonable investment decisions but
they found that they even though these
portfolio managers had a clear skill in
buying they're selling performance
actually underperformed
and they compared
what they've done on the selling side
against a random strategy so instead of
selling the stork that is that they
portfolio managers choose to sell and
they actually chose another stock
randomly from the portfolio and then
compared compared the performance of
these two strategies and they found that
the random strategy essentially
outperformed on average by eighty bits
to a percent on an annual basis which is
quite a lot considering the per support
for the portfolio size and so why is
that the case all right
they found that but for these portfolio
managers where they're very biased
towards selling stocks that had extreme
returns so either on the positive side
or on the negative side the you could
come up with you know with a proper
economic rationale as to why they would
do that yeah if your stock has an
extremely positive return you might
think well my original idea worked out
let's make sure that we lock in some of
the gains before before it crashes down
again on the other hand on the negative
side you might think well my idea didn't
really work out I probably did my
research wrong let's get out of it cut
our losses but what the authors also
found by by interviewing is portfolio
managers was that they had a very
limited attention span in the in the
selling performance right
they they only saw selling as a means to
raise funds to fund the next buys and
due to this limited attention span what
the authors essentially hypothesized was
that it is because of the availability
heuristic that they're actually shooting
these dogs because starts with extreme
returns they will be very prominent on
the media right if you if you go on
Bloomberg or Financial Times if there is
a stock that had a 20% return in the
last three months it's sure that they it
will be it would be on there and these
portfolio managers those will have
exposure to these stores and will have
them in their mind they come and come to
might come to their mind easily when
they need to make a decision as to what
to sell or what to buy and another
another good good argument as to why why
this availability heuristic might be a
play here is that they also investigated
what happens if it's not just a normal
selling normal sell but it's actually a
sell around certain events so if there's
an earnings announcement coming out from
a company does selling around these
essentially I will show the same
performance that the usual selling
tivity does and they found that it
doesn't it's very much in line with
their buying skills so they're they're
actually doing very well when they sell
on actual announcement it's only when
they really sell to raise funds that
they they underperform random strategies
so this just shows you how behavioral
biases might actually affect affect our
decision-making in financial markets so
I've not told you what what kind of
problems you have with systematic
trading and with discretionary trading
but obviously there are they're big
industries built around that I'm not I'm
not saying these are completely invalid
right I mean they have their merits and
the only thing I'm saying is that there
might be something that we can do in top
to mitigate some of these problems and
I'll show you a couple of systems that
we that we've built around making all
portfolio managers just a little bit
better removing some of these biases and
making sure that they can can compete
against computer systems and indigent
their peers in the future so what you
need to know about portfolio managers
and analysts that's traditionally the
use of technology was very limited yeah
you walk up at a shop you get a
Bloomberg terminal you get an Excel
spreadsheet and off you go
for the last 25 30 years that work well
for them so why would they why would
they change what's what's there that
they can't do in in their traditional
world well first of all it's like the
amount of data nowadays it's much bigger
yeah you need to compete with all the
systemic strategies that use all kinds
of data sources you need to compare
people with your peers which is which
are already looking at data in different
ways might use more sophisticated
technology so boom burg and Excel
doesn't doesn't cut it anymore and we're
actually bringing our Excel spreadsheets
to their limits we have a couple of
plugins which do pricing which do
analytics and but even even that it's
just just not enough to process the
amount of data that is out there
so what we are building we're basically
enriching these traditional systems with
our Python platform yeah we are building
analytics tools will building back
testers we give our analysts Jupiter
notebooks and build everything around
around our data
on top of MongoDB and our active open
source text or if our analysts are very
tech savvy that we also give them UNIX
environment which they can use to
actually schedule jobs on a daily basis
get to get more data in and and and do
even even more complex than all these
one good example of how that has
actually helped us to make our Kwan's
and our analyst better is last year in
September that was the Fang
reclassification so Facebook Amazon
Netflix Google they were reclassify
sector was reclassified and the geeks
and the Global Industry Classification
standard from IT to communication
systems yeah and that doesn't really
sound like a big deal well they they're
just moving moving from one sector to
another but one of our portfolio
managers approached us and said hey what
does that actually mean for my portfolio
alright do I have any any factor tilts
that are not hatched afterwards can I
kind of do anything to exploit this
process and will I be completely
completely under hatch and some of these
sectors afterwards so and these the
scenario knows isn't getting just
getting all the data in place and then
doing all the audio nozzles and on the
risk side probably would have taken them
our Kwan's a week or more to actually
perform but using our Python analytics
libraries and everything we have in in
[ __ ] I basically took them an afternoon
to come up with a strategy for portfolio
manager to do better and basically
navigate this exchange and talking about
data data is not really a competitive
differentiator anymore you won't be the
only user of a certain data set yeah so
in financial markets is really important
to combine data sets in smart ways to
ask the right questions visualize your
results effectively and also get get
your interpretation right so we found
that the partners and then tandas numpy
is is the perfect perfect ground for
letting our analysts do more
sophisticated analyses so that they can
actually extract value out of these data
sets and not not just get a new data set
and use it as everyone else because that
just doesn't cut it anymore but building
this platform is not the only thing that
we do I always like to think about this
as you
machine symbiosis so we are building
systems that work alongside our
portfolio managers and make make them
better at their job so one one example
of how we do that is in our Center book
our Center book is essentially a book
that runs internally looks at our
portfolio managers positions looks at
who's doing great who's not doing so
great who's doing great under what
circumstances run signals on top of them
and then trades these positions
systematically so it's basically
replicating internal portfolio managers
ideas trading them in a more systematic
fashion the one metaphor that our
portfolio manager of the center book
always uses is using Lewis Hamilton as
output for your manager yeah it was
Hamilton as a world-class driver and
what we in the contact to do is we try
to build like a mini Hamilton Robo
hammer and we try to build a system that
actually learns from Hamilton's
experience learns from his mistakes and
becomes better and better and tries to
outpace Hamilton in the long run
once that mini Hamilton becomes becomes
good enough Lewis might actually think
well this guy is doing really great and
it's just replicating what I'm doing so
what am I doing wrong so he's actually
looking at that process and tries to
find find ways to improve his own
driving bringing that to the financial
words of what we what we do is we not
only look at the positions and the
trading behavior of our portfolio
managers but whenever we find something
where they are where they have systemic
biases or whether there's something that
they can improve we basically feed that
back to them give them give them reports
have sessions with them just just
talking them through what we found and
and how how they can actually improve
their their process and obviously
finance is not the first first industry
that it's doing that anything back at a
chess when when Kasparov was beaten by
deep blue that wasn't the end of humans
winning against machines that was just
the end of humans by themselves winning
against the computer right there was a
long era of hybrid hybrid yet teams of
computers turn teamed up with humans
which were better than both the humans
by themselves and also computers by
themselves
lastly I talked about behavioral biases
and what we try to do with our system
essentially build systems that guide our
investors to make the right decisions on
their on the left and right hand side
you essentially see the the famous
bullaiah illusion on the left hand side
you would think that the line in the
middle for that for the top graphic it's
much longer than the one in the bottom
but once you put these decision
boundaries in place you'd actually see
that yeah your mind was just playing
tricks on you and they're actually the
same length so what we try to do with
our systems is essentially it take the
emotions out of the game take the
current state of the mind out of the
game of the portfolio manager and really
minimize the distance between the
intuitive solution and the correct
solution by Billings yeah designing
systems in a smart way and one one
examples of where we do that is on the
post rate analytics side here you can
see a simple visualization of a stock
price in blue and the position that I'll
put for you held in portfolio manager
held in in black the green and the red
triangles essentially a buy and sell
decisions and what that gives output for
your managers is a way to analyze
whether they went into a trade too late
whether way they they moved out of a
trade too early or whether they even
moved out too late and therefore didn't
really gain the the performance that
they could have gotten if they adjusted
their behavior obviously this is just
like an individual instance but if you
think about that in a broader scale and
basically analyze all traits of a
portfolio manager right run your Python
scripts on top of that use panels for
your 44-year in ours and then come up
with find out that this portfolio
manager is always going out of positions
too early and he's basically yeah
missing out on on Michael percent every
year just because he's he's trading out
too early and we can feed that back to
the him and basically design our systems
in a way so that next time he runs into
one of these biases we can guide them to
do to - yeah
to make a better decision and then
therefore perform better in the long run
so I've told you quite a lot about the
systems or the kind of systems that
we're building but I also want to share
a couple of the lessons learned in the
last couple of years and how you could
bring these quanta mental approaches to
life in you in your own firm in your own
own asset
manager and these are these are really I
think I think broadly applicable it's
not only for quanta mental approaches
but what we found is that you really
need to work bottom-up yeah you you can
you can be really smart about your data
signs and come up with like a really
smart system that do you think will help
them make better decisions and become
better investors but if they don't buy
into that they they just won't use it
and they won't even look at the data
they already they already overwhelmed by
what they have to look at on a daily
basis and they they can't can't can't
take anything they don't really want so
you have to find champions in your
company and try to identify real needs
find solutions for these real needs and
then make these broadly available I
think that's available in order that's
applicable to all kinds of domains yeah
you have to work bottom-up but what you
also need is is top-down support because
discretionary investment managers they
are very very focused on this this
mindset using Bloomberg terminals Excel
spreadsheets and we can do anything we
want yeah so if your management is not
behind your idea of building these
quantumatic
systems then you're basically lost from
the beginning also design and I must
admit I'm not the biggest fan of
front-end design I'm not the biggest
designer yeah you can give me the latest
machine learning libraries I'll be happy
for the next couple of weekends but I'm
not a really disliked front-end work
however it's crucial in the
discretionary environment that you
design systems in a way that they don't
hinder their current workflow yeah
portfolio managers I already have
desktops with 20 Bloomberg screens or
broker reports Outlook is a big part of
their process and you can't design
anything that takes up too much screen
real estate you really need to build
system that that work for them and that
enhance the workflow so in one way we do
that is we use something use the open
fin technology and for those of you not
familiar with what open fin does they
basically brand themselves as the
operating system of Finance and you you
get like a chromium browser and a
message bus so that you can run your
your web apps natively connect to your
to your other applications and basically
create this integrated you
experience that we want for portfolio
managers well you don't have isolated
systems but you essentially have like
one floor right you you come up you do
your analytics you come up with your
trades right one system starts talks in
to another you you push push in your
your alphas and then you can execute it
in the market immediately
lastly data and the same lesson holds
true for data as it did for therefore
for building these systems yeah if you
have to you can't really push data
top-down if you just come up with new
data sets and give them to portfolio
managers they won't even look at it yeah
you really need to look at what kind of
questions they have then find data to
answer these questions visualize the
results effectively combine data sets in
different ways and then make that data
more available that more broadly
available if people have already bought
into it so summing all of that up that
I've told you essentially yes huge merit
obviously in the traditional approaches
quant trading I discretionary trading
yeah but they're they're also a couple a
couple of short faults and what we try
to do with quantum ental is essentially
enrich to this questionary portfolio
managers investment process make them
just a little bit better then take some
of these biases away so we we are
building systems that minimize the
possibility for these biases we build
them in a way so that they are designed
to enrich and enhance their workflow and
hopefully in the long run make them
better better decision makers in
financial markets and an obviously
Python and in all the libraries I mean
you you you you've seen a couple couple
of the ones that we are using in our
group and man AlphaTech pandas numpy
they are super useful for for us and
everything in our front office
essentially built around Python and and
making making these tools available to
researchers and analysts alike before we
go into Q&A just really quick raising of
attention to our open source hackathon
in 2019 on the 2nd of November we're
working alongside you on open source
packages in our London offices so if
you're interested in contributing giving
something back to the community sign up
at man dot coms - hackathon 2019